Docteur Boileau,
Comment est-ce qu'on va arriver
à un nouveau plafond?
Vous dîtes que ce n'est pas à
vous de convenir ce qui est
acceptable ou non. Comment va
arriver à un chiffre?
- Bien, écoutez,
la première des choses,
c'est que nous réalisons,
et je pense que nous sommes pas
les seuls ni les premiers à le
souligner, que des émissions
à cette hauteur-là peuvent
poser des risques pour la santé.
On les a caractérisés en partie,
pour le cancer du poumon.
On voit que ça a un impact.
C'est pas un impact, en termes
de nombre, qui est exorbitant,
mais c'est un impact réel
et c'est un impact qui,
lorsqu'on le regarde par rapport
à ce qui est norm
accepté, nous le dépassons
beaucoup du côté de la
communauté de Rouyn-Noranda,
mais particulièrement dans
le périmètre urbain, sinon même
dans un e proximité,
qui est le quartier Notre-Dame.
Mais il y a d'autres effets
possibles de cette fonderie-là
et il faut en tenir compte.
Donc, nous nous empressons, au
s prochaines journées,
quelques prochaines semaines,
à caractériser les risques.
Ça veut dire, quand on est
exposé à ces taux-là, à 100 ou
à 80, ou à 50, ou à 20, ou à 15,
ou à 3... Et ce que nous allons
faire, puisqu'effectivement,
le gouvernement est intéressé,
tout comme, si je comprends
bien, l'entreprise, à trouver
un espace de convenance pour que
ces risques-là soient minimisés.
Alors, nous allons travailler,
avec des propositions qui
ont faites, de dire :
Bien, voilà. Si nous cheminons
pour une diminution à tel
niveau, est-ce que ça aura
t sur la santé?
Et de quelle nature sera-t-il?
Pour que les gens soient
le plus possible,
de dire : Bon, bien, voilà.
Ça, ça voudrait dire, donc,
qu'on aurait combiende maladies.
Est-ce qu'on aurait des risques
de cancers ou des risques
de bébés de petit poids avec ça,
isques même de
difficultés d'apprentissage
scolaire pour des enfants?
Est-ce que c'est réaliste,
de croire que ça peut vraiment
minimisects?cts?cts?cts?cts?cts?
Moi, je crois qu'on est
sur un chemin qui est ouvert
devant nous, puis qui va nous
permettre, dans un horizon
respectable, c'est-à-dire
prochaines semaines,
à peine quelques prochains mois,
d'arriver à une conclusion
qui sera raisonnable. Mais les
yeux et l'attention, et je vous
dirais ln que les gens
auront, autour de cette
fonderie-là ou dans la
communauté de Rouyn-Noranda,
vont compter beaucoup.
Est-ce que ce sera,
pour eux, acceptable?
C'est quelque chose qui comptera
beaucoup et qui est en route
pour être justement capté,
comme il faut, du côté
de l'établissement là-bas.
- L'acceptabilité sociale
après des négociations entre
la fonderie et le gouvernement,
ais je comprends que vous
n'excluez pas que ça dépasse
le 3 nanogrammes par mètre cube,
qui est en ce moment
la norme provinciale.
- Bien sûr que ça peut être très
difficile, pour une entreprise
avec une telle production
industrielle, de ramener le tout
à ce qu'on retrouve dans l'air
ambiant dans un contexte
où il n'y a pas d'industrie.
Ça, ça peut être pratiquement
impossible. Alors, est-ce que 3,
c'est le seul niveau acceptable?
Peut-être que pour certains
citoyens, c'est le cas.
Mais lorsqu'on explique bien
l'impact d'avoir des taux
supérieurs qui pourraient
osciller de façon plus grande,
peut-être quelquefois plus,
est-ce que c'est toujours
acceptable? Ce sera la question
à leur demander. Parce que
vous savez, les repères
internationaux, de ce côté-là,
vont varier un peu.
Il y a des repères qui sont
plus sévères, d'autres moins,
et il y en a qui sont plus
modernes. Malheureusement,
on n'a pas eu d'étude très,
très récente. On s'était
attendus, au fil des récentes
années, à ce que la grande EPA
américaine puisse prendre
une nouvelle posture de
ce côté-là. Ce n'est pas le cas.
Ça arrivera sûrement après
cette règle d'assainissement,
qui pourrait être progressive
dans le temps, aussi. Mais moi,
je crois qu'on peut naviguer
avec une certaine exposition.
Encore faut-il que
ce soit bien maîtrisé.
- Hier, il y avait le premier
ministre François Legault qui
n'excluait pas la fermeture
pure et simple de l'usine,
s'il n'y avait pas de plan
pour réduire les émanations
d'arsenic. Quel niveau
d'émanations, à votre avis,
nécessiterait de fermer l'usine?
- 100 ng par mètre cube,
ce qui est actuellement permis,
si on maintient
cette permission.
- Donc, tout ce qui est en
dessous de ça serait correct,
à votre avis, permettrait
de faire fonctionner l'usine?
- Bien, attention. Actuellement,
même si c'est 100 nanogrammes,
les mesures prises dans
les années les plus récentes...
Ça monte à 87, à peu près,
en moyenne, si on prend l'année
passée. Donc, en bas de ce qui
est actuellement pourrait être
acceptable. Mais il faut pas
que ce soit à 86, là!
Il faut que ça soit nettement
plus bas, et il faut voir la
progression. Parce que vous
savez, l'entreprise, c'est pas
en ajustant ça sur un petit
module à l'intérieur qu'ils vont
pouvoir varier ça, faire varier
ça. Ça va demander des
changements dans leurs processus
industriels et des changements
complexes, des innovations
probablement à intégrer dans
tout ça. Donc, il y a un effort
à faire et ça peut prendre
du temps. De cela, est-ce que
ça peut prendre trop de temps?
C'est ça qu'il reste à vérifier.
Donc, on n'a pas tous
les paramètres, en ce moment,
mais je suis assez convaincu que
les responsables de l'industrie
travaillent fort pour essayer
de convenir de nouvelles façons
de faire qui seront proposées
et que nous pourrons analyser
à la lumière de nos expertises
et donner un avis sur : Voici.
Si c'est ça, ça va donner ça,
et de vérifier si les gens
trouvent le tout acceptable.
Que ce soit la population,
l'industrie ou, bien sûr,
le gouvernement.
- Dr Boileau, un mot sur
la COVID. Je sais que vous allez
faire le point demain, avec
le ministre de la Santé
Christian Dubé, mais est-ce
qu'on peut s'attendre
à un retour de mesures
sanitaires, vu qu'on voit
par exemple une courbe
ascendante pour ce qui est des
hospitalisations, des personnes
en soins intensifs aussi?
- C'est une question
extrêmement importante
et qui est très pertinente
parce qu'effectivement, on voit
une croissance actuellement.
Mais cette croissance-là ne nous
amène pas dans des paramètres
qui sont profondément
déstabilisants pour le
système de soins, même si nous
reconnaissons qu'actuellement,
en pleine période estivale,
il peut manquer de personnel
pour des vacances bien méritées.
Mais nous ne sommes pas en route
pour imposer de nouvelles
mesures populationnelles.
Il n'y aurait pas les motifs
pour faire ça, en ce moment.
- Donc, on attendra quand même
le point sur la situation plus
complet demain. Dr Luc Boileau,
vous êtes directeur national
de la santé publique. Je vous
remercie beaucoup. Bonne soirée!